well more proof that no good deed goes
unpunished to Colorado Supermarket
employee claims he was let go from his
job after recording three men stealing
500 worth of laundry detergent
look at him stealing really bro you got
to resort to this
economy's not that bad
better get it while the getting's good
yeah the worker claims he did not
physically touch the laundry looters in
any way two of the crooks Got Away clean
but one has since been arrested and
that's thanks to him after he revealed
their license plate that was hidden
behind tin foil and yet he was still
fired since the supermarket bans
employees from chasing thieves the
grocery store telling a local station
quote we have security measures in place
to help prevent crime and de-escalate
such confrontations to minimize the risk
to our Associates while we are unable to
comment on Personnel matters we value
our hard-working Associates and their
safe return home so judge companies have
these policies because they don't want
the liability if someone gets hurt in
this situation but law enforcement needs
video evidence to prove who's doing the
crime right so how are you supposed to
do that if you can't take video well the
I guess the thing all comes down to the
policy and this is apparently this
Market is part of Kroger's the policy is
they do not Chase thieves or intervene
in a theft I think he should sue for his
job and by the way I'm hosting Jesse
tonight and we're going to have this guy
who was fired on the show tonight and
the truth is that he did the business
Community a favor he did the law
enforcement Community a favor he had the
right in fact under the law in Colorado
to make his citizens arrest so he could
have done all that it doesn't seem that
he contravened the policy and they're I
mean they're punishing him we are living
in an upside down world where if you
work for Lululemon I mean they end up
they end up firing you if you even say
something to people taking things you're
supposed to let them leave to what end
it makes no sense so I think that this
guy not only has a job he has a lawsuit
and by the way these people can be
prosecuted it's a misdemeanor they've
got 120 days in jail and a 500 fine Greg
it seems like they should have stolen
more if you're going to get away with it
yes I'm actually having the looters on
my show tonight you know what's funny
the one thing the other obvious point is
if he hadn't filmed it we never would
have seen it right so it's really it's
kind of important to to like actually
witness these things happening in this
era so we can tell people this was this
is not normal this just happened blah
blah blah during the during the uh the
Soho looting uh my wife was had climbed
out onto the onto the uh scaffolding and
recorded the looters got the cars and
everything and she did it and gave it
all to the cops and I think that is
you're you're basically trying to save
your neighborhood when you're doing this
and I I think litigation legal reasons
the church reasons decides you you have
to do this there is
um a weird thing where
we lot people for filming so many things
right you know oh they got there's a
fight in the airport there's somebody
yelling at a Burger King but this case
it's not entertainment this is not like
all that stuff's entertainment it's fine
but if it's actually has some kind of
moral value you can get in trouble for
it the bottom line you have to intervene
when no one else is doing anything we
see this on the subway that's how human
beings react we see a vacancy and we
want to fill it if the police can't do
it if the security can't do it you will
do it which leads me to a suggestion
this is a solution that could end this
right now when you think about it you're
decriminalizing theft right that means
stealing from them
is also decriminalized so I don't
understand why if you have a supermarket
or any kind of store
you have these guys that just hang out
and they wait till the people leave then
they take their stuff and they get like
10 you get like a posse yeah it's
basically a product Posse and so they
just hang out there and then it's like
so you get let's say they take 500 bucks
worth of stuff they get 50 bucks if they
take the stuff from them it's actually
sounds like a lot of fun for kids for a
summer job hang out you know hang out
look at so many people beaten up yeah no
if I can just get one person beating up
Charlie I've done my job no but the
thing is I don't but I guess what I'm
telling you is that if this is legal why
can't taking that stuff away from them
be legal should go steal it back yeah
it's true I mean if you're an hourly
worker who's just trying to make an
honest living I've watched this happen
in New York City and people come in and
just steal everything it's like what's
the point no I actually love that idea
um I think that uh you could but it
would you you'd want people to to kind
of know what they were doing you want
armed people to be doing and to do it
yeah but the not my idea but but the
armed components but it isn't amazing
that the that you have all this concern
about liability uh that when it where it
sort of cuts against the employees what
about the liability for the employees
you're creating I think the legal term
is attractive nuisance by having a store
that doesn't enforce shoplifting doesn't
enforce this kind of theft and aren't
you endangering your employees what and
why can't employees get together I mean
I would think that I I think it's a
constitutional right you have even if
you're at work to be able to be safe in
your environment to be able to protect
yourself defend yourself to defend
yourself have that right to do it but
does that include stopping other people
and how terrifying that I was just going
to bring that up because look in New
York City or other places around the
country where everything is locked up
going shopping as a member of the
community sucks like you're gonna order
it on Amazon you're not gonna go ask
every time you want to get deodorant out
of the store and so that closes the
security and closes jobs for these
people too it makes people not care
about where they live I'm not saying
that we all have to participate in
co-ops and things like that but you're
invested in your community right that's
why you buy homes there rent however it
is that you're living there you want
your kids to be walking safely around
the streets you want your local stores
to feel like somewhere even if it's a
chain
like somewhere where you're safe and
also that you can have a decent shopping
experience I went to my local CVS to get
some ice cream because they have the
anti-American stuff I like the benefits
and it's locked up now it's a new
development and I said I hope they throw
away the key all right okay
I said why why the ice cream right it's
embarrassing I have to call you now
every day to say I need another pint and
it's so hot out yeah what are people
doing with it you're stealing a ton of
ice cream and it'll be melted by the
corner policy meat consequences Jessica
it's the things you believe in that has
brought them to this moment in life
where you are crying about your ice
cream first world problems but Tide Pods
are also locked up I'm just saying that
nothing is fun anymore but I do think
that there is a bit of a turning point
coming
um the Philadelphia D.A krasner was
apoplectic and so distraught over this
shooting in Philly over the weekend
I think that you see those changes with
the chess Boutique blame it on who did
Larry blame the shooting on not the
shooters people wearing pins I mean the
guy is clueless
as a D.A and that's the end of it well
it's not because I can still finish what
I had to say the point is that I think
that there is becoming a slow
acknowledgment among some of these
liberal politicians that you will not
lose favor or support you will in fact
gain it if you call things out that are
going on like for a London breed for D.A
krasner we saw in San Francisco Eric
isn't that sad that that's how you
measure it that you have to be grateful
yeah yeah
now we'll do now we'll do it because I
think we won't get criticized yeah you
should be doing it because it's like the
way you're only going to save your
community you know not just because it's
a popular thing for you crazy
easily well the judge will have Santino
barolo on the show tonight
yes watching that hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else